HE'S ONE OF THREE GOAL TENDERERS
BORN AND $23
MILLION.
QUICK SHOT OFF THE DRAW.
FOUGHT OFF BY GRUBAUER.
AN AWFUL PLAY.
PUCK TOWARDS THE NET.
THIS IS WHERE SEATTLE HAS SOMOM.
HE WILL RIM IT AROUND.
MAKES ITS WAY T FIVE ON THE YEA.
WATCH AS THIS PUCK WHEELS
ARNOLD.
LINE.IS EXACT
DRAGS WITH IT, ANDVING IT ACROS.
ANDN PAIRS TO
THE OF THE NET.
WATCH THE TO THE
EBERLE COLLECTS THE PUCK, THROWS
IT ACROSS -- OH, WHOPOINT.
BENN GETS SHOVED TRYING TO FIGHT
HIS WAY THROUGH THE SANDPAPER
FROM
GIORDANO, RIGHT WING.
ONE TIMER.
SAVE MADE BYW THAT'S SOMETHING
DON'T HEAR TOO MUCH ABOUTCE FOR.
LAYS DOWN.
BECAUSE HE ISIS
HE IS.
HE IS A PUSH FROM DO IT
AFTER HAVING DONE IT FOR SO LONG
BLOCKED.
RAFFL RUNS INTO TRAFFIC.
IT IS FUNNELED LOW.
HOPS OFF. WIDE.
CAROM OFF THE CORNER.
AND IT IS GOURDEDE PURSUED BY L.
STARS CAN'T CONNECT ON AN THE N
LITTLE BODY OF WORK  THE 4-2
LEAD.
OLEKSIAK FIND HIS NET. THERE, BO
IN IN FRONT.
THE
OPPOSING NET MINDER.
>> Brent: IF YOU HAVE SEEN THE